الايام اللي احنا فيها مشاهدينا عم تشهد
احتفالات العالم في اعياد الميلاد وان شاء
الله ينعاد على الجميع بالخير والسعاده يا
رب على الرغم من مرض السرطان اللي بيعاني
منه لاعب كره القدم البرازيلي الاسطوره
فهالشيء ما منع عائلته من الاجتماع
والاحتفال بعيد الميلاد على طريقتهم في
مستشفى
باولو واللي بيتعالج فيها نجم كره القدم
البرازيلي البالغ من العمر 82 عام واللي
دخل المستشفى من نهايه فبراير كانت في
ليله نشرت صوره للعائله من غرفه المستشفى
عنوانها بانه كل العائله تقريبا موجوده في
المستشفى الامتنان والحب والاتحاد والاسره
هو جوهر عيد الميلاد وانتشر فيديو على
تويتر لابنتي ليله عيد الميلاد وبيظهر
بالفيديو الاسطوره الرياضيه بيليه ولكن في
حاله محزنه للاسف
باي باي
[موسيقى]
السرطان اللي بيعاني منه للاسف دخل
المرحله
ومشاكل في القلب كمان وكل العالم بانتظار
اخبار عن صحته وتطورتها
[موسيقى]